what I came to realize and I've really
come to realize over the last couple
months is that super human
Supernatural really allows you to tell
the most superhuman stories because you
kind of slip it in so yes while there is
obviously this bigger it's a metaphor
for really the demons in our head
because that's what scares us and you
know discussing anxiety discussing
loneliness the isolation we've all felt
and we can use sort of this world to
tell really important stories why was it
important to insert anxiety in this this
is also what I thought was interesting
well I think that the Youth of today
they face so much and I see it in my own
children I see it in myself you know we
have 24-hour news cycles and
everything's online and it's so much we
need to learn how to use it and what I
learned is that anxiety actually is your
body running at Peak condition and so if
we stop looking at it like a problem but
learn how to harness it that will
ultimately become our superpowers